Right, I am a little
bit stuck right now.
So what I do when I have a bug, and I
can't quite pin down what's causing it,
I make the feature that's broken,
simpler.
So I take out, take components out
until I have a working feature again and
then I gradually add them back in.
And then each one that I add back in,
I'm tweaking to fix it.
>> Gosh, there's a lot of
different ways to be stuck.
But if I'm writing something that has a
lot of calculation and somehow it's not
coming through the way I expected,
sometimes it's best just to start over.
There can be something powerful about
starting again with a blank slate, and
rewriting something.
>> Sometimes when I get stuck
in the developing process
because I'm frustrated or
I just don't really,
I can't see how to get from where
I am to where I want to go.
I find the smallest possible thing
that I know I can get done, and
I just go after that.
And a lot of times just closing
that tiny little gap, that easy
chore that had to be done, is enough
to just sort of get you going again.
>> So when I get stuck, it kind of
depends on the mood or the reason.
A lot of times I get stuck because I'm
just using poor debugging practices,
and being lazy,
instead of actually digging through the
debugger and finding out what's wrong.
Other times, if its more of
an inspiration thing, I'll just go for
a walk, get outside, get away
from the computer for a while and
then come back to the project.
>> So when I get stuck,
my first instinct is to go to
the team that I'm working with.
I find that everybody
has different skills and
different expertise, and
leveraging that is to your benefit.
So a quick hey,
have you seen this before?
Do you have a fix for it,
is always worth a try.
Barring that, I go to Google, and
normally it spits out something
like StackOverflow.com.
But sometimes it also goes to
the Apple documentation, and
just carefully reading the methods
that are provided to you,
the properties that are provided to you,
and trying to find a way
around the problem instead of through
the problem can often help fix your bug.